[Music]
you are one of those lucky people that
can travel
anywhere yes ma'am and they sometimes
call you
nomads
my mom said that you're homeless is that
true no i'm not
homeless i'm just houseless
not the same thing right no
my husband worked at the usg mine in
empire
i was a substitute teacher it is a tough
time right now
you may want to consider early
retirement i need work
i like work
welcome to badlands spa
what the nomads are doing is not that
different than what the pioneers did
[Music]
i think fern's part of an american
tradition oh he's gonna come right
through the class
my dad used to say what's remembered
lives
i maybe spent too much of my life
just remembering
one of the things i love most about this
life
is that there's no final goodbye
i've met hundreds of people out here and
they don't ever say a final goodbye
let's just say oh i'll see you down the
road
and i do i see them again
and i can be certain in my heart
[Music]
i'll see you again
[Music]
you